hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
today's gonna be a shorter video there
wasn't any blog post or anything like
that but there is a few bits of
information that I want to update you
guys on on what's going on throughout
the week and what's coming next week so
as long as like the baby do enjoy
subscribe if you're new let's get into
today's video so a lot of this stuff is
gonna be focusing on the Wulin as it is
Chinese New Year so as to celebrate the
Chinese New Year there's gonna be
discounts on the elite outfit and the
mythic outfit for the Wulin that being
art of war and trimming blossom
respectively the art of war as you're
seeing here is now four thousand seal as
opposed to seven thousand it's an elite
outfit so you're not gonna be getting
anything crazy like a new effect or
anything but it will give you an
ornament and a new color swatch with the
new mythic outfit here being dreaming
blossom this is the one that we've
always had and it's been in here since
the very beginning of the Wulin so and
sadly we they still don't have another
mythic outfit but you can get this if
you want for ten thousand steal for the
next seven days as it is discounted for
a little bit but also on top of that
foreigners gonna be up to sixty seven
percent off because of this Lunar New
Year you're gonna be gonna be able to
score big on some sales like the
marching fire edition the year three
pass and probably the year one passed as
well and maybe even the actual whole
game so if you got any friends that want
to play for honor as well definitely let
them know about this deal or if you
haven't gotten any of the editions the
year three passes whatever it happens to
be definitely go do that but do be aware
year four is right around the corner and
while there isn't a pass that we know of
at the moment we will he'll probably
have to spend some money on the battle
passes but that is neither confirmed nor
denied so just keep that in mind but of
course with the marching fire edition
you get the four Wulin heroes so
basically every hero except the newest
one being soon dot with the PvE Arcade
Mode to multiplayer modes you get the
whole gist and with the year through
pass you get the champion status all
that beautiful [ __ ] you're seeing on
screen here and that's gonna be ending
at January 30th and also we can't forget
about the stuff happening next week on
the 30th of January we're gonna be
getting a lot of different juicy stuff
of what's happening for the faction war
and maybe some other stuff for a year
for whatever's happening to the game in
year four it's all gonna be probably
coming out this 30th and since those
content of the week and me you know
covering this stuff for so long I'm
going to assume that executions will be
out next week if they do not come out
next week I'm gonna be severely upset
but if they don't I'm going
to assume the week after that maybe two
weeks after that but seeing as there's
content of the week here none throughout
the entire month so far besides the very
beginning of January and we're so close
and we're currently in the off season
and approaching year four I have a high
probability that this is going to be the
new execution so definitely keep out
save your steal all that beautiful stuff
you know what to do
especially since we're pairing it with
the execution or challenge honestly the
pieces are there and I think this puzzle
is complete by this point blocked on the
channel next week keeping notifications
on we're gonna be talking a lot about
that year for stuff once we get all that
information battle passes maybe a new
hero I know the new hero is not coming
for another couple seasons but maybe
it'll show a teaser who knows what we're
gonna be getting next season we're gonna
be knowing a lot of stuff and on top of
that the testing grounds are still going
live for the breach stuff and this hero
trials going to be going through the
30th so a lot of stuff is happening on
the 30th a lot of things are ending
testing grounds the hero trial the deal
that we talked about before but we're
also beginning a lot of new info coming
in the future for this game so as always
like to be if you do and restive Scott
Murphy new I cover the informational
site a foreigner that being the balance
changes the hero updates the patch notes
in the leaks if you want to be kept up
to date with everything happening within
the world of foreigner and never miss
out on an update that if you subscribe
the channel that guys I'll see you next
week
peace out have a great rest your day
[Music]
you
[Music]